uh what was it like working with Paul
Walker you remember it did you work yeah
man that was my man
um I uh you know I met Paul at a reading
we did Varsity Blues and I did a reading
with him
and the whole cast uh
and it was the first time I met him we
did a reading at this the Red Lion Hotel
in Austin and they said hey you know
there's only one car per two cast
members
and uh we you know I knew that he had he
surfed and I surfed I'm like hey you
want to share a car he's like yeah let's
share a car that day we were doing like
donuts in the car by the end of that day
we got an apartment together and by the
end of the shoot we were best friends
training Jiu Jitsu together
you know wow going like he was he was my
that was like the first actor friend of
mine like that we were tight tight tight
and then you know my relationship with
Paul was always
um we didn't have to see each other for
a year and then we'd pick up right where
we left off you know we did that other
movie together into the blue and
um he was always
uh he was I feel like we had a lot in
common man he was a he was a downer dude
and well not to say that I'm a Down to
Earth dude but I mean we just liked a
lot of the same stuff
and he was a no non-hollywood
type of dude I mean he's I still till
the day he died I'm pretty sure he never
really turned his cell phone on you know
I'm sure really I mean you know he like
he was always the guy that his agent was
trying to find and couldn't find he was
off on a camping trip he didn't give a
about I want to be that guy he
didn't care about Hollywood at all at
all
um that's why you liked him I think too
a big part of it probably but I mean
listen I liked him he was like into
motorcycles and cars and Jiu Jitsu and
he was Scrappy and that's another thing
people don't know about Paul Walker he
was a tough tough you got advice kid you
don't want to fight Paul Walker you
didn't want to fight him he's so pretty
that you'd think that he's soft but that
dude he was the first to jump out of the
car if there was a beef he was the first
to go protect a woman if she was getting
Mister like I remember a story where he
was at a bar down south and some dude
was like pushing his girl around and the
dude was like this big bodybuilder dude
and like was like you know what you got
to say pretty boy and Paul knocked him
out and broke his arm you know what I
mean like he was a tough tough dude wow
um and I never hear that stuff it's the
truth man he was you didn't you know you
I mean ask anybody who really knew him
he was he was a he was a real one man
and it's funny because he just looked so
he was so good looking and he you know
you wouldn't expect you wouldn't expect
it but he was a he was a tough dude man
he was a good doing a
it's a bummer it was a real that's like
that was a shock that one stuck me
because he had a lot more to do and you
know
but anyway all you can think of is I
guess in those moments is hey he always
played by his rules it was his he had a
good life he made his thing he did for
sure that's that's what you hope for for
sure